like many businesses across the valley
the las vegas farm
located on grand teton and tanaya has
been hit financially by the pandemic
eight news now reporter kate houston
spoke to the owner who says
these setbacks aren't stopping them from
moving forward with fall activities
the las vegas farm in the northwest is a
sanctuary for animals that have been
abused or neglected
every animal here comes to us in trouble
every animal
comes to us in a horrific state
sharon lynson bart owns the farm and has
dedicated her life to rehabilitating
animals
but it comes at a cost feed alone is
more than 7
thousand dollars a month due to the
pandemic the farm lost its steady stream
of field trips and weddings
without those sources of income it's
really difficult for us to be able to
feed and care for these animals that are
in trouble
lindsen bart is now looking towards fall
hoping it can give them the boost
they need during the fall season many
families come to the farm to feed
animals
like hazel here and pick some pumpkins
and despite the pandemic
the farm will be moving forward with
some family friendly activities
in a safe fashion lyndsen bar plans to
sell pumpkins but spread the area out to
keep families distanced she tells me the
farm has hosted fall festivals for over
40 years
she wants to continue that tradition
with the families that come in here
with this openness that we've got
everybody can stay far enough away from
each other
to be able to have a real fun day in the
meantime lynson bart is keeping the farm
open every weekend so the community can
browse their farmers market
and interact with the animals and that
will keep helping us until we can get
back into
our field trips and our weddings and the
other things that bring in
enough money so we can continue here
kate houston 8 news now
if you're interested in donating feed or
supplies you can head to the las vegas
farm dot com
they're also now looking for volunteers
for the upcoming fall season